who do you think's the favorite in this
tournament besides me right I think all
players are very strong every person
here is so strong player so it's just a
thrill asan tournament to say don't go
together why just 11 because he's very
strong and as there are many very strong
player so you know it's the kind of
tournament that everyone can be first
and the last I think maybe Nana did I
think she's like a really strong player
and who'd be nice to to play against her
like we played once but it was in blades
tournament so let's see what what will
happen in classical chess definitely
because of top seed in like now no
question yoke they could be the favorite
so according according to the readings
I mean objectively like Alexandre should
be the favorite according to the rating
even so I think in this tournament is
the way the lineup is now I believe
everybody could win this tournament
because everybody has the strength to do
so I think so
it's really a matter of current shape so
I wouldn't even predict the outcome
because it could be any outcome all
players are strongly enough to win those
tournaments
difficult to say all girls are pretty
strong even though maybe like the rating
favors didn't show up for certain
different reasons but I mean every
single girl this tournament can win it
in this field I think it's a very
balanced field it's really hard to just
pinpoint a favourite I mean I do think
the ladies who've been consistently
rated around like twenty five fifty for
a good portion of their careers are
certainly you know favourites you know
like Alexandra and Nana
Alexandra Castillo because I think he
she's so top seeded right and you like
you I don't know I never thought about
an inch so carefully
and she has more experience to play an
American maybe a little bit more or less
I think the level is the same so I
cannot say just one but you never know
these tournaments like anyone can do
well one on the given days as here are
all the top players I think and so
that's why everyone is dangerous and
Xena Valentina could be a very dangerous
player as well
but I think it depends on everyone's
form because it's a very close field